La siguiente tabla muestra los valores de
los puntos ("x", "y") de la gráfica de una función lineal.
Determine la intersección en "y" de esta gráfica.
Recordemos que la intersección en "y",
si se imaginan una línea
en una gráfica como la que voy a poner ahorita...
tenemos aquí el eje "y"...
el eje "x", los marcamos...
"y"... "x"...
e imaginamos nuestra línea que va más o menos así.
La intersección en "y" va a ser cuando "x"vale 0,
así que la coordenada de este punto de acá va a ser, 0 porque "x" vale 0,... y bueno aún no sé que valor vaya acá,
pero va a ser un valor de "y"...
cuando alguien preguntar por la intersección en "y",
los que les preguntan en realidad es cuál será la coordenada cuando "x" es igual a 0.
Viendo la tabla, encontramos el valor cuando
"y" es igual a 0, (2, 0),
esta es la intersección en "x"...
ésta es la intersección en "x", que sería ésta de acá.
Pero la que nos están pidiendo es la intersección
en "y", ponemos la de "x" de todas maneras (2, 0).
Y bueno, vemos en la tabla no nos dan ningún
valor aquí donde "x" sea igual a 0,
pero quizás nosotros lo podamos inferir usando
los valores que nos dan.
Voy a reescribir esta tabla para tener un poco más de espacio para escribir otros puntos que quiero inferir.
Vamos a escribirla de este lado
para que no se confunda.
Tenemos aquí el espacio para la tabla, aquí
va a ir la coordenada "x",
aquí va a ir la coordenada "y" y escribimos,
bueno, de -2 a 8... -2, 8...
Ahora, yo quiero calcular cual será la coordenada
para -1 en "x", para 0 en "x"
y bueno, aquí retomo los valores
que ya me están dando, que es...
1, 2...
2...
0 y 4, -4...
Veamos, qué pasa cuando "x" pasa de 1 a 2,
cuando "x" aumenta en 1,
aquí aumenta en 1,
¿qué pasa con el valor de "y"?
Vamos de 2 a 0, de aquí a acá se restan
2 ó se decrementan 2.
Y como esto es una línea, la pendiente va
a ser constante, es decir, el cambio en "y"
con respecto al cambio en "x" no va a cambiar,
de manera similar, cuando "x" es -2 y queremos
que pase a -1, es decir, aquí aumenta 1,
¿qué va a pasar con "y"?
ya vemos que esto es constante, se va a decrementar
en 2, entonces este 8 le vamos a quitar 2,
¿y aquí qué nos va a quedar?
Nos va a quedar un 6.
Sigamos, ahora, si de -1 incremento 1, aquí
le sumo 1, me va a quedar en 0, sigue cumpliendo,
ahora a este 6 le tengo que restar 2, para
mantener el cambio constante,
¿qué pasa cuando le resto 2 a 6?
me va a quedar 4, (0, 4) .
Ahora, cuando a 0 le aumento 1,
de aquí a acá, tiene un 1 agregado, pues aquí se está
cumpliendo, este 4 le restamos 2 y nos queda
2, así que esto se está cumpliendo.
Ahora, qué pasa cuando a este 2 le agrego
2, no le agrego un 1, le agrego 2,
ah, pues aquí se va a decrementar de 0 a
4, se va a decrementar en -4,
le vamos a quitar 4, que sigue
cumpliendo esta proporción.
Entonces lo que se mantiene constante es el cambio...
el cambio en "y" con respecto al cambio en "x",
esta delta, este triangulito de aquí, se
llama delta,
es una letra griega que indica cambio
El cambio en "x" entre el cambio en "y"
se mantiene constante y vimos que esto es igual
cuando "y" cambia en -2...
-2...
"x" va a cambiar en 1, en 1 positivo.
Así que esto es -2 y de hecho ya respondimos
lo que nos pedían sin darnos cuenta,
¿cuál es el valor de "y" cuando "x" es igual a 0?
Pues es 4.
Es este 4, que ahora lo podemos sustituir acá, 4.
Y ésta es mi intersección en "y", aquí
"y" vale 4, aunque no grafiquemos esta escala,
eso lo dibuje, como quien dice, a ojo de buen cubero.
Vamos a hacerlo un poquito más apegado a
la realidad, tengo mis ejes "y", "x",
los etiqueto para no confundirnos, "y", "x".
Y ahora vamos a ver las proporciones, vimos
que éste es en la coordenada 2 de "x",
vamos a ver,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, éste es el 2...
y vamos a hacer lo mismo con "y"...
Éste es 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
y éste es...
1, 2, 3, 4...
la coordenada (2, 0), es ésta (2,0)...
que lo pongo de otro color, aquí para que se note...
y la coordenada (4, 0)....
4... no, no es (4, 0)...
no, no, no, no, no....
la coordenada 0, ya que "x" es 0, (0, 4),
ok, ahora sí.
Entonces si unimos estos dos puntos, ahora
sí voy a tener una recta parecida o bueno,
más realista con respecto a estos datos.
Entonces unimos este punto con éste...
más o menos por acá...
y lo voy a extender para que se note mejor... ok.
Y esta es la línea que nos están indicando
con estos puntos de la tabla.